listen what you just said was that
America got all emotional and did a
bunch of stupid wrong things after
September 11th Israel ought to listen to
you and they ought to not do that they
ought to be smart and look I wrote an
article a couple of weeks ago and and we
do need to get into why Netanyahu likes
Hamas so much and supported them in
Palestine uh because that's a huge part
of this okay because we get we keep
getting distracted off our points and
probably that's mostly my fault but um
uh and hell now I forgot what I was
going to say about that talking about
the you were you were leading to the
comment uh the the link you sent which
is something that I was oh the reaction
retion the reaction okay so look okay
yes you guys are familiar with sa
Alinsky the leftist radical Community
organizer guy right okay page 74 of
Rules for Radicals says that in all
asymmetric political action the action
is in the reaction of the opposition